it didn't feel like a three-hour movie
like I it was good like the dialogue
wasn't too nerdy like it was actually
good [__] it's because they're they're
speaking in such like a like a slightly
older inflection of English that it's
easier to understand because everybody
yeah because you're not hearing like
different regions you know what I mean
yeah
[Music]
did anybody play Monopoly as a kid yes
sir I love that game I still play it we
should play yeah let's play that would
actually be fun but also probably take
like five hours and we probably break
friendships here and it'll be hard to
edit don't let me be Banker I will
[__] cheat I will [__] [__]
regardless I will [__] yell and
scream and steal your money but what
about Monopoly they are the the Monopoly
movie live action movies back on the
board after Lionsgate has acquired E1
from Hasbro so now they're trying again
to make a monopoly movie can't wait
there was already one no the script and
the idea had already been put together
but like you know until like there's so
many Hollywood like rights and politics
in terms of figuring out who gets well
ownership and IP and stuff but yeah
what's the premise I wonder well the
thing is you know Ryan was saying this
uh earlier before too it's like
especially in the era of Barbie and like
you know thinking about there's a market
corner it opened the floodgates of like
IP that's different though Barb did you
guys see Barbie that's [__] good it
was good
technology Cardinals gonna crush it yeah
Bart doesn't think so Bart thinks that
this movie's gonna suck you think that
Barbie's gonna suck that's what I
thought but you said it's good we just
said it's good you thought's gonna go
walk and go bro he said it was going to
be as good as [__] Green Lantern the
original run rental I didn't even know
if the movie was like a good movie I
just thought that it was gonna Crush in
sales and it was gonna bring people back
to the theater it did you know my
ignorant ass thought that Oppenheimer
was gonna help Barbie no no no no Barbie
helped Oppenheimer I watched Oppenheimer
Oppenheimer is a [__] amazing
you guys see it in the 70 um I know but
they're [__] even 6 a.m on Sunday was
sold out one of my buddies yeah because
70 millimeter for IMAX like the the
[__] Film LA and dude it's all La
though because like that you know
everybody's [__] film I like how you
guys are gonna [__] buy IMAX to watch
one scene hugely big and everything else
is talking scenes yep my buddy watched
Oppenheimer the theater
the 70 millimeter they showed them the
first hour
in the third hour and they skipped the
second wait what wait what they [__]
up they [__] up the projectionists oh
because when they switched yeah so he's
watching it he's like that's a weird
he's like
I don't know this is weird why did you
see the video of them bringing the
Oppenheimer IMAX thing it's like 55
miles long or some [__] in a big spool
yeah these guys are like what the [__]
man [__] you Christopher Nolan dude like
for what didn't they do it in the format
too that was so [__] up for theaters I
forgot it was because even when people
shoot things in like 70 millimeter like
Dunkirk or random stuff like that they
get digitized at 70 millimeter this one
is film oh yeah so they're actually
running if you're watching 70
millimeters you're actually running
films or something I I actually thought
there were gonna be more explosions and
actions and things to make it
justifiable but like it was literally
two and a half hours of talking but
here's here's the gangster part of Nolan
though his contract on it was to make
sure that his film would take over all
IMAX theaters which meant that it [__]
up Mission Impossible dead reckoning
because that came out a week before but
this the second oppenhower comes out
every IMAX theater has to cut Mission
Impossible
dude I heard it's like crazy sold out
nobody can find a showing it's crazy
sold out dude I we tried I think the
third time is when we actually were able
to find decent seats you just have to go
to like a wack theater yeah that's
different La is [__] snobby
mcnabberson you know lamb uh [__] uh
North Hollywood oh yeah totally empty
IMAX no 70 millimeters available at uh
the Chinese Theater and it was I think
it was just regular it was just like
regular thing but nobody saw it there
dude I'm telling you Christopher Nolan
just filmed a play
like what the [__] what was it good I
didn't see it I saw barbie barbie was
the [__] Barbie was good Barbie looks
like the better viewings yeah I will
like it but I don't want to see I don't
need to see it I don't even see it
[__] entire train you don't you know
if I watch the standard I think it would
I think I could see why it would help
pay attention if you're not used to
watching dialogue heavy movies can you
finally hear what the [__] going on in
the Nolan movie are you actually you
like actually can in the beginning you
feel like it's going to be really
difficult
but it got resolved afterwards but it it
doesn't it didn't feel like a three-hour
movie like I it was good like the
dialogue wasn't too nerdy like it was
actually good [__] it's because they're
they're speaking in such like a like a
slightly older inflection of English
that it's easier to understand because
everybody yeah because you're not
hearing like different regions you know
what I mean yeah
but if you're a history buff and the
types of people that pull up like Albert
Einstein and this and that and you're
just like Albert it's like oh that's
[__] dope like the homage and all
that and the little yeah yeah yeah I
heard they did some improving in a
little bit which is unusual for a Nolan
movie
like when the bomb went off one of the
one of the generals is like that was
[__] fire
but dramas typically just don't do as
good as Blockbusters and branded [__]
like it's just one is for the whole
family and one is for like snobs yeah I
will say my favorite meme from the
barberheimer entire like Trilogy or
concept yeah Barbara Ann is what they
call it is that uh Barbie was uh made in
Japan sold in America and then uh the
atom bomb was made in America
[Laughter]
it's honestly the best movie I've seen
this year really really wow Bart doesn't
believe me no dude wait first of all
Spider-Man across the spiders I didn't
see you okay never mind do you think
that was better than Barbie yes yeah yes
you're a Spider-Man guy though are you
you saw you you saw barbie too yeah I
also saw barbie yeah it was just very
good very good very good I gotta watch
that next but Spider-Man
literally like even from just an art
medium was just like Innovative and
Revelation it's very hard to beat that
is that a movie that you need to see in
the theaters
not necessarily I don't think there's
any of those anymore their their writing
is just so good did you watch the first
one yeah the writing is just is too good
writing is good our animation is good
music's [__] good the whole way they
set it up is just brilliant I'm a little
superheroed out but I'll get to it if
you recommend it I'll get I don't want
to watch any superhero [__] right now
bro that's the crazy thing I'm so all
the all the [__] like the Blue Beetle
or whatever from DC is is actually like
uh predicted to be the biggest flop in
super hero movies The Flash just was so
far did you watch The Flash I did I
liked it you know I kind of liked it I
liked it even though some of it sucked
and I'm okay with that because some some
things that are tasty are so fun Keith
Batman was worth it oh I could see that
being worse cheating Batman I'm such a
surprise yeah maybe such a [__]
person for people that like want to grew
up with that generation of Keaton Batman
yeah because a lot of people didn't
that's my Batman yeah that's why it's a
[__] for Batman like him just being like
you want to get nuts oh my God that's
all of us are like yeah I'm I'm a [__]
for [__] freeze
every pun every pun yeah unfortunately
so good and uh news flash this isn't
about Monopoly anymore oh so what other
IP we know that they're gonna [__] IP
everything now because Barbies they're
gonna make mouse trap they're gonna make
Don't Wake Daddy GI Joe they're gonna do
GI Joe they did Battleship already
remember that yeah they're gonna reboot
it don't wake daddy as a horror film
it's pretty [__] sick it's a good
spooky song Imagine they do don't tweet
you're just giving it to them imagine
operation
I feel like it has to be brands that
survived and it's in the memories of uh
like Millennial gen Z but also it's
still around today for so it's like
families can go and enjoy the brand yeah
but Barbie was just a huge one because
Barbie is synonymous in my opinion to
like like Bart had mentioned like
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles but TMNT is
already in the Seth Rogen reboot which
is like the eighth [__] variation
yeah they're just reselling whereas
Barbie is like the first of all kinds
right like what other major I mean even
even Glass Onion is essentially clue
over and over wow yeah exactly even the
most recent Batman movie right which I
haven't completely watched but there
were so many moments in it because I
kept falling asleep you mean that reason
you might read one that was just
completely ripped off from when I had
already seen in other Batman movies
already and so it just it just doesn't
have that same like like oh this is new
I've never seen this on screen yeah so
what's a what's something that survived
like Barbie that's still relevant till
this day that a whole family can go and
oh dude the Jenga movie you're gonna
watch the Jenga movie that'd be cool I'd
watch wait there's a Jenga movie dude
I would have [__] watched it I was
like don't [__] with me right now [__]
is the Jenga movie gonna be about Barbie
just did so well though there's gonna be
an everything movie now and what I can't
wait for though is when they're like
like Vox is like why the Hungry Hungry
Hippos movie like promulgates the
patriarchy
you actually shouldn't be having a good
time at the theater this weekend yeah
exactly that's animal rights activists
talking about hungry hungry you know I
think they could do
um
Hot Wheels Hot Wheels I thought they did
a yeah that's on the list oh they
haven't done it yet no not yet not yet
well I think in cars but it's on the
list of uh of uh green lit films to come
yeah yeah Hot Wheels seems like it could
be that's a no-brainer they're doing Hot
Wheels yeah is it Hasbro or Mattel Hot
Wheels it's gonna be a Need for Speed
movie are there toys that survived from
our era that like taika plays with
there's ones that have expanded like
crazy like Nerf like oh my nerves Nerf
is now in pet stores too what like they
shoot tennis balls out for dogs to go oh
that's cool is there anything that's
like IP like cartoon Lego that stuff oh
Lego killing huge Lego movies but they
have Lego movies yeah Lego movie is
amazing Lego Batman was good like yeah
yeah Lego Everything dude Lego Star Wars
because I wish like some of the stuff
that we grew up on stayed like Biker
Mice from Mars gargoyles Street Sharks
hiker mice
no they are doing the Gargoyles the dude
that was in tennis is directing it um
that'll be so awesome that's a great
story dude I remember um SWAT cats you
ever watched yeah remember small cats
with a K yeah yeah that was a sexual
make them do Thundercats and we'll see
DuckTales dude we need them back
but live a concept of live yeah live
action Ducks is like they did live Alvin
and the Chipmunks yeah that [__] kind of
sucked out that sucks but Taiko watches
seven thousand times yeah we're talking
about like multi-generation yeah yeah
when you watch when you watch like
Barbie we're adults and we're like yo
that was good but obviously even like
little girls will still be like whoa how
do you do a sequel to Barbie by the way
they the Barbie movie is a
deconstruction of like a lot of
different things doing a sequel that's
gonna be impossible because they they go
out of the world right do you think
they're going to is that what they're
obviously they're because they smash
well they probably have to know whether
they want to or not Greta Gerwig already
said she doesn't know how the [__] she's
gonna do it yeah because they go out of
that world right that's the best way to
market the sequel but they completely
just unless they already have the second
script and she's like I have no idea how
to do this
I mean even if it sucks it'll probably
make its money back yeah yeah I mean if
they could do it to Matrix
but did they Nations for socked man
[__] I just I mean I'm one of those
fans that I'll watch anything Matrix
because I'm just dying for that world I
watched it too it doesn't mean it was
good they did play with them with four
[__] on Matrix Four I really hope they
uh he broke the the the third wall too
much huh the the last one oh dude the
movie thought it was so much smarter
than it was that's I hate that [__] yeah
in fact after the second one with the
mayor of vegina I was like you guys
think you're so [__] smart you know
what this [__] you know what Matrix Four
was it was like uh it was like the Harry
Potter reunion of the first movie that's
all it was it felt like a parody movie
yeah like it didn't feel like the
trailer facial explorer was like
remember how amazing woman was sick like
when I saw the trailer for Matrix Four I
was like this can't be it yeah it looked
like a music video it looked like like a
like a student film yeah it was weird
that is true I hope they start making
movies out of ips that aren't even toys
they like Sharpie the movie
that'd be [__] funny or like Sharpies
or like a movie about the [__] floss
thing that you put like this okay
the
movie The Band-aid the movie Club the
movie
right yeah
[Music]